there's a story at the bottom of this
hey there what up friends so
um I have an interesting mission for
today I am teaching the last session of
my live stream class uh for this unit
tomorrow night and I have to put
together a bit of choreography to teach
the class so I thought I would walk you
through the process by which I create
and shoot my choreography Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today we are
taking a look at choreographing yay but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
all right so first things first I need
to pick some music for this choreography
to be written to my students went ahead
and uh basically suggested a bunch of
different options in our last class
session so I'm going to go through and
see what the samples of each of these
songs sound like on Tick Tock and see
which ones I'm feeling like using all
right our first Contender is Believer by
Imagine Dragons
[Music]
yeah I'm not really feeling the vibe on
this one kind of feels like it takes a
little bit too long for the beat to drop
we've also got Time Bomb by Walk the
Moon
so I like the vibe a lot more
um I'm having a hard time picking out a
good starting point for the choreo in
there though so we're gonna we're gonna
leave that as a plan B for right now
here's another suggestion Dear Maria
Count Me In by The All-American Rejects
I think we have a winner I like that
there is a bunch of changes right off
the bat so there's some easy places for
me to stick in some changes I think
we've I think we've got our music so
next step will be to set up the camera
outside and start working on choreo so
let's head out and do that
alrighty then so this is not my usual
practice spot but I think it'll still do
we have what I reckon is probably like
an hour maybe two hours of sunlight left
so uh usually it takes me about an hour
to choreograph one of these things and
get a decent take of it so let's get
started on that now shall we all right
so the unit we were just learning was
all on horizontal plane tricks so
playing around with a lot of corkscrews
a lot of horizontal flowers uh and of
course our final week we talked more
than a little bit about plane breaking
so the challenge for me always is coming
up with choreo that is going to look
interesting but still is simple enough
to pass on to folks that are still
somewhere near the beginning of their
POI Journey so one thing that I think I
want to incorporate into this off the
top of my head I was thinking about this
in the shower this morning is kind of
taking some elements of the plane
breaking that I worked on with the class
last week and turned that into a little
phrase to start with and see where we go
from there
magic down
okay so straight up at that moment when
the uh it goes half time for a second
there is absolutely going to be a
pirouette with a horizontal flower at
that moment there has to be
[Applause]
I kind of like starting it off with just
kind of like the over-the-shoulder kind
of thing right here I don't know it kind
of feels dramatic like uh uh you ever
see that uh cover of Spider-Man where
it's like Spider-Man no more and it's
like you know looking over his shoulder
as the uh as Peter Parker is walking
away from his costume
I don't know why I I get drawn to comic
books because it's very bold uh kind of
shapes that the bodies are getting into
I think it's cool
so I think I want to go from that
horizontal flower into a corkscrew and
trying to figure out the best way to do
it so the challenge is that as I'm
coming around in that flower I need my
right hand to lead the corkscrew up and
it kind of feels like when I get to the
end here well I suppose I could just
lead with that right hand as it's coming
around
and yeah because in that way I just do a
quick beat on bottom and then the
corkscrew is the next thing that comes
out of it
[Applause]
huh that might be something
so idea is to take a pendulum out with
the right bring it back take it around
around bring it in
and fold left hand goes around around
bring it in and around to fold we push
them both back down come out and around
we do our Corkscrew which I let on the
wrong hand there and we come down kind
of take it down like so we wrap around
let me try that with music
[Music]
I like it I like it a lot now what comes
next
foreign
yeah so I think I want to get to the end
of those lyrics right there okay so that
is like another uh somewhere between
seven to eight seconds thus far we have
played around with plane breaking
we have played around with horizontal
flowers
and we have played around with
corkscrews
so is there anything else we can bring
in here let me see what happens just if
I rock out with the music for a second
[Applause]
okay so I forgot there was one other
thing that we played with uh in my class
and that was you to stalls okay so we
start to my left right left bring them
up and around stall take them around up
over
there's got to be a more dramatic way I
can end it than that stall stall
tuck turn around
tuck turn what if I went up high and
then down low
let's see where that lines up with the
music shall we
all right I kind of love that but I want
to do a little bit of tweaking of some
of the body language here so like when
I'm doing the wrap up rather than it
being like you know semaphore here I
think that I want to like have it be
more of a flex all right so just to mark
that we're going to take it down and
around up and over around my shoulder
bring it around and huh we bring it up
take it around whoops that's going to be
a problem we take it up we take it
around we take it around bring it around
and
I think I want to like lunge slightly in
that direction and then drop and then
that will be my cue because I'm kind of
already in a plie here to take
that around then I can take
my Corkscrew this boom boom
yeah I kind of want to I want my body to
have a response to these uh stalls so
boom as they come up and around we go
around
really emphasize that
and as we go down I want to make sure
that I'm I'm doing like uh that Greek
discus thrower here yeah again superhero
power poses what what can I say all
right so let's try that again with music
[Applause]
all right so notes for myself this thing
where I'm wrapping up
um I think that the hand facing inward
might not be the move here
um I'm wondering if I can
yeah kind of do a thing where it still
flexed but my hand is now kind of
pointing more outward so something like
that rather than something like that
also I'm noticing coming out of this
Corkscrew I am
really the the the movement downward is
kind of awkward I'm trying to figure out
if like Ah that's what I'm looking for
so I need to open up as if this is a
horizontal flower and that's what's
going to that's what's going to guide me
down also as I am doing this little
thing off to the side here I really need
to make sure that the line I'm creating
with the POI is actually horizontal
instead of off at a diagonal because
that's kind of awkward and finally
coming down I need to that this is the
pose that I need to hit right here I
need to make sure that I'm focusing on
the negative space around me all right
let's give it another go then shall we
thank you
yeah that was a disaster let's try that
again
[Applause]
pancakes
[Music]
sweet so I'm feeling really good about
that and I want to try it for a final
take I'm going to shoot this with a uh
an s-log so I can do some really nice
color correction like that and now let's
see if I can get a winning take out of
this
oh man that was a real good take the one
and only thing was I didn't feel like I
nailed that shape at the end perfectly
but um that's going to be a good backup
it's really close
oh snap our work here is done as of
right now that clip is up on my
Instagram Tick Tock and YouTube so
please go and remix or duet or whatever
it is that you prefer to do with your
platform of choice uh Pretty Please Come
Dance With Me I hope you enjoyed
watching the process of me putting that
choreography together
there's a story out
here
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and of course to help my channel grow
hey friends Drex from the future here
with a real special message if you dug
that choreography please come take the
POI dance classes that I wrote it for
we're going to be starting up a new unit
on Tuesday June 6th and we're going to
be covering body tracers check that out
over at crowdcast.io drexfactor POI
hopefully I'll see you there
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible where
not for the kind sport of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of my other
videos on POI Dance I'm going to go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
said videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here because it is
popular amongst people that visit my
channel uh thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today I
hope you learned this bit of
choreography uh have a good one and
enjoy the flow peace